regardez-moi ça est-ce que c'est pas
assez extraordinaire là je suis avec
micro scope directement sur l'île de
mandji je suis en x 15 et là je suis en
x 30 et fois pour connaître quand même
qu'il ya un vrai effet whaou
[Musique]
ce nouveau smartphone c'est le au pot le
réno 7 et aujourd'hui deux vidéos qui
réalise un partenariat avec hop hop on
m'a dit tiens monsieur bruce que tu
pourrais présenter leur est notable et
c'est un produit qui vraiment est allée
sera long lorenzo 7 c'est peut-être pas
le smartphone de l'année parce qu'on est
sur un smartphone qui coûte tant d je
voulais tout de suite j'ai le prix 329
euros 90 s'est pas particulièrement cher
ça reste un gros budget mais c'est pas
très élevé c'est intéressant 4 329 euros
90 c'est la première fois qu'on vient
retrouver un microscope dans un
smartphone et c'est une techno copeaux
avait déjà mis en place avec son find x3
pro il ya un an et on avait une caméra
micro scope alors pour autant c'est
différent mais c'est intéressant donc là
j'essaye de venir ajouter directement
c'est sur un panneau en fait c'est une
pub regardez-la déjà je suis en x 15 on
voit quand même tous les petits points
qui permettent de faire la couleur en
voile bleu on voit le rouge et compagnie
et ensuite on passe en quatre ans dans
ce cas c'est marrant mais regardez ici
c'est qu'en fait on a une règle en
millimètres où vous voyez 06 09 mm si
vous permet de mesurer ce qu'il en est
si vous avez réellement besoin ou envie
de mesurer ici là on est sur une plante
alors c'est pas très évident comme ça et
ça permet de redécouvrir un peu le
vivant alors là je vous ai mis en x 30
directement et c'est assez marrant parce
que une fois de plus vous avez vraiment
là la règle pour voir là où vous en êtes
et là on va passer on va prendre un peu
de recul on est en x 15 alors je vais
pas dire qu'on voit mieux qu'on comprend
mieux mais bon c'est un métier d'avoir
une perspective un peu différente et on
voit qu'on a changé au niveau de la
mesure voyez donc ça c'est la même
plante mais en fait qui a été tournée
ont des eaux de la plante on voit tous
les petits poils sur la planche trouve
ça extrêmement bluffant c'est une
feuille en fait d'une plante donc on
voit là la pilosité suppression parle de
pilosité je pense pas qu'on parle de
pilosité élan x 30 on va beaucoup plus
d'eux bluffant une fois de plus pris
garde et là c'est une espèce de tache
qu'on a à l'intérieur également
en fait ici vous avez trois caméras pas
une pas deux trois caméras celle qui
fait office de micro scope c'est
celle-là ça c'est votre caméra
principale de 64 mégapixels il ya même
une fonction de fusion où on vient
regrouper plein de pixels pour vous
sortir une photo de 100 8 mégapixels bon
c'est pas forcément ce qu'on va venir
rechercher mais si on veut on peut le
faire on a un autre capteur pour la
profondeur qui est celui-là qui s'en
vient pour notre portrait plus un
troisième capteurs qui est le fameux
capteur ici convient retrouver pour le
microscope
[Musique]
le microscope et justice y est ce qui
est super ex microscope c'est qu'ils ont
eu une petite lumière ici en cette
petite lumière il peut paraître assez
gadget mais en fait vous en avez
réellement besoin pourquoi parce que
sinon vous y voyez rien une fois que
vous avez plaqué votre smartphone en
tout quelque chose donc la voyez je me
mets sur ma main alors forcément que je
décale un petit peu et je vois ma peau
alors se trouver un peu la position ici
vous avez aucune stabilisation donc
forcément ça peut être un peu galère
mais regardez voilà on n'a jamais vu un
mes poils d'aussi près donc ça c'est le
x 15 et après je peut switcher en x 30
même position savièse ou mais en fait
numériquement et regardez on vient voir
quand j'ai la peau c'est chez moi qui
trouvais que j'avais une peau pas trop
dégueu quand je vois ça je me dis que là
j'ai vraiment une pause et gallas il va
falloir faire quelque chose
[Musique]
pour bien s'hydrater les mains merci au
pot de m'avoir permis de me rendre
compte que j'avais les mains trop sèche
bon ça vous me direz c'est assez gadget
c'est clair ce smartphone c'est faire
autre chose regardez comme je vous le
disais vous avez une caméra principale
de 64 mégapixels qui vous permettra de
venir faire des photos partout temps
très facilement directement depuis
l'application alors l'application elle
est très simple c'est une application de
au pot donc bien d'un go ici le truc qui
m'a un peu surprise s'habituer à voir
des ultra grand-angle et si on n'a pas
du tout donc effectivement on est sur un
voisin est uniquement un voisin après on
peut venir zoom est passé en x 2 c'est
tout du numérique froid à 5 et jusqu'à
fois lisse vous avez un mode portrait et
mais bon c'est pas vraiment de quoi
venir chaque smartphone mais est ce
qu'il est intéressant déjà avec le foie
ça c'est un sujet qui m'intéresse côté
photo je trouve que dans l'ensemble
c'est plutôt bien ce qu'on a sur le
capteur principal ici en trois ans on a
bien les tailles dans les nuages on a
bien la façade plutôt bien fait donc ça
ça marche bien on peut venir nous met un
peu en faut de mon avenir d'éviter
d'aller plus loin x 5 et une fois disent
que ça ramène beaucoup de bruit
qualitativement n'y ai pas regardé là
c'est pareil sur le ciel de paris plutôt
bien c'est assez efficace toujours un
peu les mêmes un reproche ici sur un
coucher de soleil chaud ça aussi plutôt
pas mal parce qu'on a bien aux façades
avant on a bien tous derrière ces photos
et je trouve intéressante pourquoi
regarder parce qu'en fait vous avez un
ciel avec un espèce des fins peu cotonou
au travers des nuages qu'on me retrouver
sarah c'est plutôt sympa on voit bien la
matière on a de la texture donc ça
fonctionne c'est pas la voir le piqué
d'un gain sur ce smartphone mais malgré
tout ça va on peut venir vous m'aimez
tout de suite voyez c'est un peu moins
bon et vous allez voir on le voit un peu
ici sur les hautes lumières il a un peu
plus de mal et c'est ce qu'on retrouve
un peu sur ce smartphone de façon un peu
globale par contre ce que j'aime bien
c'est ce qui va ressortir au niveau des
nuages ici souvient côté un peu très
grandiose qui est très très sympa et qui
fonctionne bien de la même manière ici
place de la bastille regarder on a bien
cette masse de nuages qui est là et qui
donne un côté un peu plus monumental le
truc que je veux dire peut-être apport
prochaine c'est qu'on voit pas
effectivement ici et bien la colonne qui
reste vraiment très très très sombre et
bon voilà il n'y a pas de compenser ça
est pareil de la même manière ici ça
fonctionne dans l'ensemble plutôt bien
alors c'est les photos sont prises en
plein jour donc bon il n'y a pas de
souci que je pense pas qu'il faut tonus
fois les meilleurs ici sur ce smartphone
on est sur un smartphone milieu de gamme
c'est pas là où ce sera le plus dingue
on voit qu'on a un petit peu de mal ici
au niveau des hautes lumières car il ya
un autre truc à savoir si c'est que vous
n'avez aucune stabilisation optique donc
si vous bougez ça va bouger et moi je
bouge donc ça bouge n'y a pas de miracle
la caméra de cette fille c'est la caméra
statique vous avez dans le finepix 5
procamera de sel fille plutôt haut de
gamme mais qui je trouve à quelques
petits défauts au niveau des hautes
lumières on vient de retrouver ici voyez
sur le front et dans les cheveux et je
ferai le même reproche ici sur la caméra
celle ci voyez on le voit là là là là
c'est cramé et c'est pas très bon au
niveau de la caméra micro scope ça
raconte quoi je trouve ça c'est marrant
on fait ce côté microscope parce qu'on
vient découvrir des choses qu'on ne
verrait pas à l'oeil nu et c'est plutôt
pas trop mal alors on va pas avoir la
meilleure qualité c'est pas un truc de
fou mais je dirais exactement la même
chose que ce que je vous ai présenté
cette caméra c'est sur le finepix trois
pros l'année dernière c'est à dire que
ça permet de redécouvrir le monde alors
au delà du côté un peu gadget gens
regardent sur mon jean je le fais une
fois que je n'ai plus jamais le truc qui
est intéressant c'est par exemple pour
moi voyez pas ce que je vais avec mon
fils avec elliot et bien on peut prendre
le smartphone on peut aller dans le
jardin et redécouvrir le monde qui nous
entoure différemment regardait ce que
vous saviez qu'une plante s'est fait
comme ça avec des espèces de deux poils
on n'est pas tous les jours avec une
loupe au sol et la bud avec votre
smartphone donc c'est à côté
effectivement un peu gadget mais je
trouve que quand on veut se réapproprier
le vivant qu'on veut le partager
notamment avec des enfants ou même soit
son envie de se marrer ben je trouve ça
assez efficace et pas que pour ça c'est
le malin au niveau de la vidéo sur son
smartphone je peux filmer uniquement en
1080p enfin au maximum je préfère du
720p sait pas forcément ce qui va
m'intéresser mais c'est pas forcément un
smartphone qui va être là pour faire de
la vidéo mais si vous voulez vous pouvez
mais en 1080p maintenant il ya un autre
qui est vachement intéressant et si au
niveau de ce smartphone c'est son design
et son look il est extrêmement fin et ça
c'est un truc qui est assez dingue aussi
vous allez pas forcément vous en rendre
compte comme ça moi c'est lorsque j'ai
pris en moins que gelée ouvert il est
très très faim il extrêmement pas garder
ça comme c'est tout mini c'est tout mais
nier ça c'est bien parce qu'en fait on
envoie des smartphones on envoie des
jeunes gens pèsent des tonnes mais des
smartphones aussi fins et très très très
rare mais pour autant c'est un
smartphone qui fonctionne bien leur a
pas de problème va pas vous lâcher n'ont
pas oublié de mettre des composants à
l'intérieur en plus de ça il a un côté
un peu rectangulaire au niveau des
formes là je trouve plutôt bien on a
effectivement ce blog photos là qui
vient légèrement dépassé ça me pose pas
de problème et ont plus de sacs en tout
cas c'est marrant c'est que là alors il
existe différentes finitions ça c'est
une finition noire avec le hop au boulot
on est sur une matière plastique on
n'est pas sur smartphone avec un dos en
verre c'est vraiment un plastique mais
ils ont aussi un effet avec un orange
avec un effet cuir je dis bien et fait
parce que c'est pas du cuir qui mais qui
est sympa qui est un poil plus lourd et
un poil plus épais mais de quelques
millimètres c'est vraiment pas grand
chose moi ce côté au pogo et cet effet
là je laime bien je trouve assez sympa
sur le côté au pont rompu son le sens où
le doyen il ya un côté un peu relief qui
est assez marrant après c'est un
smartphone il est très classique vous
allez retrouver votre capteur
d'empreintes digitales qui permet de
déverrouiller extrêmement rapidement un
truc assez sympa ici aussi c'est que
vous avez cas d'un grand écran c'est du
6,4 poussée de l'amoled de l'amoled à je
vous dis une fois de plus il pas appris
les prix par contre j'aurais dû
l'apprendre par coeur 329 euros 90 et de
l'amoled alors il ya un truc qui est
intéressant et c'est un choix qu'a fait
au pays si haut pour effet le choix de
mettre un snapdragon 680 qui sera
uniquement 4g est pas s'engager alors
c'est vrai qu'on se dit aujourd'hui
tiens c'est bizarre parce que tous les
constructeurs nous met des smartphones
5g on a discuté avec au poète on dise un
choix on a préféré ne pas mettre de
modem 5 g de rester sur un modem 4g
travers du choix de ce processeur bien
évidemment pourquoi parce qu'en fait il
ya beaucoup de personnes qui aujourd'hui
ne veulent pas la 5g ou n'ont pas encore
de la 5g leur bien évidemment la 5g se
démocratise de plus en plus mais tout le
monde n'a pas de la cinquième ce qui
fait que si vous avez un abonnement
kadjé si vous voulez de la 4g mais que
vous voulez un smartphone de bonne
qualité avec de bonnes finitions et bien
nous en avions ici qu une fois de plus
le tarif je retiens parc pas y arriver
avec ça mais ce qu'ils nous ont dit
c'est qu'en fait ils ont préféré ne pas
mettre ce processeur qui permettrait
d'avoir de la 5g mais à côté de ça ne
pas rogner sur la qualité et vous mettre
en écran de bonne qualité ce qui fait qu
ici vous avez une dalle amoled cdu 6,4
poussée du amoled et le amoled c'est
quoi le amoled c'est des contraste
infini c'est une qualité qui sera
supérieure au lcd ici sur un smartphone
dans cette gamme de prix et donc ça
c'est un choix qui est intéressant en
plus ici ce qui est intéressant c'est
que vous avez un taux de
rafraîchissement qui va jusqu'à 90 hertz
donc pour du gaming ça apportera un peu
plus de fluidité du gaming mais pas que
du gai mais si vous venez scrollé comme
190 hier c'est bien vous aurez un peu
plus de fluidité pour votre regard ça
sera un petit peu mieux et vous avez un
taux d'échantillonnage d'actifs de 180 m
alors au pot nous a dit par moments sur
une action un peu spécial dans un il va
monter jusqu'à 1000 hertz mais que sur
un moment il va savoir que la bien il se
passe quelque chose et on a besoin de
cette réactivité au niveau du taux
d'échantillonnage tactile va monter à
1000 r et il va redescendre à 180 c bon
c'est de la petite optimisation mais
pourquoi pas et en plus de ça vous avez
un écran qui est certifié lutter contre
la lumière bleue fatigue oculaire vatan
ça c'est bien il ya un autre truc que
nous fait au pot qui est intéressant
c'est des optimisations logiciels alors
ici on a coloro escaut l'oreille je ne
sais pas si vous connaissez bien alors
je vous ai fait une vidéo pour vous en
parler de cible ou très bonne expérience
logiciels chez android donc si vous
voulez un bon android avec une
expérience qui très cool vous pouvez
aller sur coloré sans aucun problème
vous pouvez me à personnaliser beaucoup
de choses aller voir ma vidéo le dessus
y franchement c'est très très cool bien
un truc qu'ils ont faits qui est super
intéressant au niveau de l'expérience
logiciel vous venez ici dans un propos
de l'appareil vous avez de la ram
virtuel alors vous explique la ram elle
est là ici vous voyez vous avez 8 gigas
de ram et 128 go de stockage mais vous
pouvez venir augmenter votre ram de
façon virtuelle c'est à dire ça fait
quoi ça vient taper dans le stockage et
sa mère récupérer une partie de stockage
pour l'attribuer à la ram ça va servir
notamment lorsque vous avez plein de
l'application bref ça va optimiser un
peu l'histoire va pas raconter une
nouvelle histoire mais samedi à
optimiser un peu les choses que vous
voyons venir choisir ce que vous voulez
en attributions drame virtuelle soit 2
gigas soit 3 giga soit 5 gigas comme
vous êtes déjà 8 gigas ça vient booster
un peu et puisque je vous parle
d'optimisation logiciel insight qui sont
assez marrant c'est qu'ils ont mis de la
veille adaptative alors ça peut paraître
un peu barbare comme nom comme ça je
sais pas si par exemple vous lisez un
article sur votre smartphone et que vous
avez mis que au bout de 30 secondes et
bien il va se mettre en veille alors ça
sera un peu ballot lorsque vous regardez
un article que vous 30 secondes il se
met en veille il faut appuyer dessus
pour remettre la luminosité c'est hyper
relevé sauf que là le truc qu'ils ont
fait est assez malin veut dire que
lorsque vous êtes en train de lire votre
smartphone vois que vous êtes en train
de lire et il le sait alors ce pas qui
vous espionne en permanence c'est qu'ils
ont créé un algo qui permet de savoir
lorsque vous avez les yeux focus dessus
ça fait quoi ça fait que l'écran ne se
mettra pas en veille ça c'est cool alors
ils ont fait un autre qui est aussi
intéressant lorsque vous recevez par
exemple une notification et que vous la
regardez hop ça vous la fiche si
quelqu'un qui vient qu'un petit regard
malicieux sur le côté qui regardent hop
afro voit plus rien ça la fiche plus
sont des petites optimisations mais qui
font la différence et qui sont vraiment
intéressantes et ici d'un point de vue
purement logicielle avec color ouais
sauf un truc qui marche bien alors après
il ya un autre qui est aussi intéressant
je sais pas si vous connaissez au pot
ils sont vraiment connu pour la recharge
très rapide avec de la superglue ici
alors on a de la super vous que c'est
pas la super vous que la plus vous qui
est du monde c'est quand même de la
super vous qui est rapide c'est la
recherche 33 watts qui vous permet de
recharger assez rapidement votre
batterie est de 4500 millions terrain en
fait le truc qui est intéressant ici
c'est qu'on n'est pas je dirais dans un
réno tel qu'on le connaît si vous
regardez l'année dernière je vous ai
présenté leur est nocif et reno si ce
projet était beaucoup plus cher ici on
est à 329 euros 90 des 329 euros 90 pour
un smartphone de au pot c'est pas très
cher parce qu'en fait au poids fait le
choix de ne pas sortir tous les rénaux
il faut savoir que en chine ils sortent
des smartphones sous le nom reynaud sous
la gamme raynaud tous les six mois
c'est-à-dire vous en avez deux parents
donc nous le dernier qu'on avait eu sept
lots raynaud 4 on a eu lors une hausse
si l'on n'a pas eu une renault 5 voyez
par exemple les sorties comme chez nous
on n'a pas eu ici pour qu'on retrouve un
réno 7 qui est quelque part un réno 7
sans être réellement raynaud 7 qui est
moins haut de gamme car no6 ce qui
justifie aussi la différence de prix on
comprend mieux effectivement mais à côté
de ça ils ont fait un truc assez marrant
que c'est pour ça que point voulu sortir
cette année c'est à dire un smartphone
qui est très fin qui vient trouver sa
place dans la gamme d'euros pauvres
c'est qu'aujourd'hui les constructeurs
ont besoin d'avoir de plus en plus de
produits parce qu'une concurrence qui
sauvage donc il faut des produits il
faut des smartphones et en plus de ça il
vient se différencier avec sa caméra
micro scope donc en fait ce smartphone
je trouve assez séduisant je trouve
assez intéressant sera pas fait pour
tout le monde voyait mais un budget de 3
129 euros ben vous savez quelque chose
qui fonctionne bien vous avez déjà
l'expérience coloré ce qui est très
bonne vous avez une petite led de
notification que vous allez retrouver
ici lorsque vous recevez un appel un sms
un message de quoi que ce soit vous avez
un truc qui a ses membres au niveau du
microscope vous avez une caméra
principale qui marche plutôt bien ça ça
fonctionnait également un package qui
fonctionne 329 euros pour moi vous en
avez pour votre argent de la recharge
rapide 30 3 bat donc ça c'est cool donc
sereine au 7 cl vous fait de l'oeil et
bien vous pouvez l'acheter leur
attention ce lien vous trouverez pas en
boutique au pot a fait le choix de ne
vendre que sur le web sur le store de au
pot par exemple je vous mets le lien en
bas d'un description s'il vous intéresse
mais si vous avez un budget aux
alentours de 300 euros vous voulez une
bonne expérience couvre un appareil qui
tient la route raynaud cei vous pouvez y
aller les yeux fermés et ça c'est cool
voilà dites nous ce que vous en pensez
en bas en commentaire on se retrouve
très vite très bientôt pour continuer à
parler tech et vous allez voir bientôt
je vous le spot très rapidement on va
rebouger ya des choses qui se passent on
va aller voir ce qui se passe un peu pas
l'autre bout du monde mais presque ça
c'est cool vous embrasse pour les soins
de votre éviction
[Musique]